Jeffrey welcome uh back to the studio
tell us your strategy for today's game
against Hans is definitely a player that
is hot right now in this competition uh
stringing up victories one after the
other you were slowing down in last few
rounds what was the strategy going in
today
round yeah Hans was definitely in good
form and me not so much so the idea was
uh just to play something solid um I
think he caught me off guard with with
Bishop G4 in the opening which I wasn't
anticipating and after that I just tried
to liquidate things that was our
impression as well because this bishop
G4 is more of an off bit line but
generally with the help of the engines
nowadays is considered to be okay did
you analyze this at home at any point in
history yeah I have many Blitz Games
here I tried Knight E2 as well Knight E2
or or F3 and it's all more yeah Knight
E2 let's say Knight E2 uh cd5 H3 Bishop
H5
C4 you can see that I have some games
here yes Jeffrey versus raay Robson and
these are Blitz Games you
saying that one maybe was rapid but uh
in general it's yeah it's a normal
position I could have went for this I
wasn't sure which to try but in the end
I selected the game variation but I
think he played it very well he played
it very well and at this point were you
worried at all after the queen landed on
F2 he was trying to create something he
was trying to keep the game going were
you getting worried at any
point uh maybe slightly I don't know uh
perhaps after Bishop F like in the game
Bishop F6 gf6 Rook
B2 I wonder if he could try something
else besides Queen H4 cuz he had he had
either Queen E3 or queen
D4 not sure which but let's say queen
yeah Queen 3 I guess it's it's still
okay after Rook bb1 this is what I also
saw
um yeah it looks kind of unpleasant but
in the end maybe it's fine yeah and it
didn't seem like you or him made any
mistakes and finally you found not this
repetition but this transition into a
technical drawish end game Jeffrey how
would you assess your performance so far
obvious vious L you probably are not
happy especially with the last couple of
games what are you going to do to turn
things
around yeah it's not been great so far
but just got to keep going um tomorrow
another tough game with black I think
against Wesley so take it one game at a
time and see see what I can do that
seems like a very uh good strategy
Wesley we'll see oh sorry Jeffrey we'll
see you tomorrow we'll see you against
Wesley tomorrow
good luck Jeffrey
indeed